I'm Johansson Hoover I'm originally from
Holland I've been a clock maker and
repair for a lot of 12 years so the
process to make a wheel is by having a
wheel cast first would you call it blank
you remove the skin of the blank by
filing it off or scraping it off once
you've done that you mark a center hole
a center punch drill a hole in it we use
a dividing plate in order to set out the
correct number of teeth onto the wheel
you then set out the teeth on the wheel
with a device which allows you to mark
or scribe lines on it so if you have a
wheel at 60 teeth you can have you can
mark 60 teeth on to the disk
once you put all the lines on it you
file down beside the line you cut out
the gap in between your teeth
finally you shape the tip of the teeth
and that's done by hand filings and the
last that you do is and file off the
crossings and that's kind of the process
when I cut the wheel and especially
whenever for instance cut the teeth you
get into a flow and like you get into a
rhythm and that kind of like using the
hand tools to shape the teeth or you
know make a crossing is a kind of like
almost therapeutic way of of working you
get kind of into your own world and what
people always forget when you make
something is how much time it takes I
can make a wheel in a day but then
that's only one wheel if you want to
make a whole clock you know a year it's
kind of nothing I always feel very
satisfied when I finish a product or an
item well you have more respect for
things that are being handmade
you